träge durch die schafherde im schatten
der bäume die ersten lämmer des jahres
sind da deshalb hält schäfer florian
preiß die 240 tiere zurzeit hier
zwischen lagerhallen und fabrikgebäuden
bei oberhausen im westen deutschlands
sonst ist der mit der herde auf
wanderschaft auf den grünflächen der
industrieregion preis ist einer der
wenigen schäfer dies überhaupt noch in
deutschland gibt berufe war in
deutschland ist nicht die menge
ich kenne die junge leute die es noch
machen wollen
ich meine leidenschaft weiterhin machen
dass ich den hier machen muss und ist
mit sicherheit auch sterben bei hof als
es hat keine bottrop und verdient hatte
ich hier dabei man wird halt nicht
reicht dabei die schafe bringen ihn geld
durch den verkauf des fleisches und weil
sie gegen geld öffentliche grünflächen
ableiten
früher war auch die wolle ein gutes
geschäft heute deckt der verkauf erst
mal die kosten für das scheren der
schafe schöne landschaft wolle ich mit
meinem land schaffen da die qualitativ
von einer der besten die beste wahl
haben kriegt noch über 1 euro pro kilo
kollege von mir die anderen rassen haben
die kriegen halt noch deutlich weniger
geld pro kilo
das ist dann 45 65 cent pro kilo die
verkaufen die von teilweise gar nicht
mehr sondern nicht verbrennen die
deponie preis wolle geht nach china
dort so zäh weiterverarbeitet und landet
im bett waren polsterungen teppichen
oder in der textilindustrie produkte die
zum teil wieder auf den europäischen
markt gehen und dort teuer verkauft
werden
schneiderin brigitte pappe bringt das in
rage
es ist total absurd wenn man überlegt
die aufkäufer hier kaufen die wolle auf
schicken die nach china zum waschen und
dann wird sie wieder zurückgeschickt
nach paris dann ist dann verhandlung und
dann ist sie auf einmal toll
regierte papa hat sich das schneidern
selbst beigebracht eigentlich ist die
gelernte zahnarzthelferin
doch jetzt ist sie unternehmerinnen mit
einer leidenschaft für wolle ihr
neuestes projekt mosel suite deutschen
fan von harris tweed bin was ja auch was
wolle ist habe ich mich damit
auseinander gesetzt ob unsere schafe
hier in dieser regierung
ob diese wolle geeignet ist für ein tuch
und sie ist sehr gut geeignet für ein
tuch und das war dann so der grund wo
ich gesagt habe okay dann kümmere ich
mich jetzt mal um das retten der wolle
den stoff lässt sie in deutschland
herstellen ausschließlich mit wolle aus
ihrer region
100 meter hat sie schon mit ihrem
mitarbeiter näht sie daraus westen
mützen und sakkos unterstützung bekommt
pappe von der wagenfelder spinnerei den
stoff in einem globalisierten
textilmarkt regional herzustellen ist
schwierig zu hoch sind die
produktionskosten zu geringen die mengen
auch papas wolle wird hier verarbeitet
gefärbt und zu einem faden gesponnen
deutsche rolle spielt im internationalen
markt jedoch keine rolle
so bekommen unsere wolle aus der ganzen
welt bekommen sie von neuseeland
australien und südamerika
ihr bekommt ja auch aus england wir
beziehen unsere rolle je nachdem welche
ansprüche das hier erfüllen müssen
bekommen wir unsere wollen von überall
her auf 220 tonnen neuseeländischer
wolle pro monat kommen hier zehn tonnen
deutsche wolle pro jahr
der rohstoff aus down under als
massenprodukt ist reiner etwas weicher
effizienter produziert und deshalb sogar
billiger weber unterstützt das projekt
glaubt in naher zukunft aber nicht an
das big business mit deutscher wolle
nicht bereit mehr geld zu investieren
mehr geld offen aufladen tisch zu legen
für ihn ist die schnelllebigkeit wichtig
die mode der mode wechsel und dafür muss
es möglichst billig sein
hier muss ein umdenken stattfinden
seriösen schwert
brigitte pappe glaubt trotzdem an ihren
stoff auch wenn sie oft noch teuer ist
die nachfrage nach nachhaltiger kleidung
wächst papas ziel ist es irgendwann
10.000 meter mosel suite in auftrag zu
geben
eine massenmarkt wer sie damit aber
nicht bedienen
also mein erstes ziel ist es nach macher
zu finden ich will keine millionen ich
möchte zufriedene mitarbeiter ich möchte
am ende des monats wissen dass ich ein
einkommen habe für mein auskommen
und ich möchte mit allen die an dieser
kette zusammenhängen also mit mir
zusammen arbeiten gerne mit mir
zusammenarbeiten weil sie einen preis
bekommen der ihrer arbeit wert ist